et maintenant
lui
insolent et les
voici maria pacôme
bakhoum bonsoir soir
est ce que tu disais je pouvais pas te
tue le prenne mal s'il savait gérer son
volet qu'à celui des lèves tu penses à
navès djamel ouais enfin ceci étant le
décor il est mieux depuis que tu n'as
nick et moi je sois si je traverse tout
de suite oui si tu pouvais pas partir
maria pacôme rebond soir alors je vois
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus roger hart
qui vous habite donald cardwell kivu
décor vous êtes plutôt habillé comme un
cas comme un journaliste journalistes en
irak de la baisse de de son ami jacques
scène particulièrement des petits gilets
mois correspondants de guerre un petit
peu là le look ça va maria très bien
bien
alors donc j'étais à la fiche de mauvais
esprit de patrick alessandrin avec
thierry lhermitte ophélie winter
clémentine célarié michel muller je cite
attaché de presse est toujours inscrite
gavard je sais pas si elle est en
coulisses catherine laurence astrid et
l'a donc astrid surveille et si des fois
je parlais pas assez bien du du film
mauvais esprit tu pourrais venir voilà
alors légèrement
elle est charmant nadal c'est que
c'était mon assistante astrid oui mais
je sais tu dis on a vu avec la gaule du
matin
elle n'avait pas dit ça peut vous dire
en tous les cas que je l' ai toujours
respectés à elle m'a pas dit ça non plus
alors le pitch bas côté c'est très
simple clic sur les esprits c'est
l'histoire d'un mec qui n'a vraiment pas
de pot dans la vie qui est incarné par
michel muller jusqu'au jour où il meurt
renversé par une voiture conduite par
thierry lhermitte et il va renaître dans
la peau du bébé que thierry lhermitte va
avoir avec ophélie winter et il est prêt
à tout pour se venger bref c'est une
espèce de sheer nez comme on dit sur les
affiches du film c'est une excellente
idée de vraiment c'est un film c'est une
très bonne idée c'est le genre de
scénarii que les américains nous rachète
en général parce que c'est vraiment
c'est très fort la réincarnation du
sieur dans le bébé alors évidemment
chaque fois qu'il voit thierry lhermitte
le déteste vous alors alessandra avait
déjà fait 15 août que tu as un bon film
15 8 et 13 août il ya toujours des gens
qui ont des bonnes idées
alors vous vous êtes la mer donc de
thierry lhermitte la belle-mère de finir
winter et vous êtes appelés à un moment
à la rescousse pour contrôler cet
affreux bébé à mons voulais me dit ah
oui on est de mon stress d'ailleurs oui
il ya trois mois ya le petit alors oui
c'est ça qui m'a attentes et d'ailleurs
qui m'a fait que vraiment refile
immunitaire c'est une horreur là moi je
suis une horreur on se traite mais comme
mais vraiment c'est assez vrai c'est
vrai qu'il ya des rapports n'ya pas y'a
pas un sourire las des rapports d'une
violence entre windsor et vous
il m'est arrivé qu'il n'existe pas
jamais jamais ça moi je connais pas très
très violent c'est très très violent
alors on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
purement parle